welcome ladies and gentlemen to our
discussion of health Scott's sobering
new book connecting the connectedness
and contagion here it is and if you
didn't notice we have copies for sale
out in the hall it's my pleasure to
remind you that you're welcome to buy a
copy and that he'll will be available to
autograph them during the reception
which will follow immediately after the
panel I'm Alex Pollock of the R Street
Institute and here we are in a stylish
new conference center to discuss a very
old problem namely how best to survive
financial panics in which there have
been many across the centuries how to
survive the contagion of fear and
distrust when financial actors try to
withdraw from risk to protect themselves
a rational strategy for each but as we
all know not when they all do it at the
same time this is highly interesting
historically but much more pressing when
we consider as hell's book does in
scholarly detail what we'll be able to
do in the next panic which asura
assuredly will arrive sooner or later
two centuries ago David Ricardo
accurately observed quote on
extraordinary occasions a general panic
may seize the country when everyone
becomes desirous of possessing himself
of precious metals today that's of
Treasury bills or equivalent against
such panic
Ricardo concludes banks have no security
on any system that is to say the private
banks on their own Walter Paget
commenting
on this statement in 1873 draws the
conclusion we all know was true then and
is still true now to wit if all the
creditors demand their money at once
they can't have it
moreover Badgett goes on when
apprehension passes a certain bound no
private banker is safe for as Badgett
also says every banker knows that if he
has to prove he is worthy of credit
however good may be his arguments in
fact his credit is gone and that's what
happens in the panic everybody's credit
is gone because nobody can prove he's
worthy of credit and are not even sure
about their own solvency well what do
you do then then you have to finance the
bust so the central bank and the
government's Treasury provide new debt
and as hell says also new equity
expanding their own balance sheets so
everybody else's balance sheet can
shrink expanding their own risk so
everybody else's risk can go down and
that's what you have to do if you want
to avoid driving asset prices into a
wild downside overshoot hell's book
discusses how this survival process has
been made much harder by the post-crisis
legislation in the US and have notably
the dodd-frank act and he interestingly
points out how this is notably different
from other countries so for example he
says the United States is rather unique
and it's apparent resolve however
unrealistic it may be to forswear any
use of bailouts in the future hell
predicts there will be bailouts in the
future but that there'll be a lot more
cumbersome slower and harder to do and
he predicts that in time we will greatly
regret the changes which have been made
if they're not corrected before the
inevitable next crisis and that those
changes will
in the the next time things a lot worth
a lot worse hell is going to present his
book which will do for about 25 minutes
then we'll have comments from our
outstanding panel whom I'll introduce at
that point our author Hal Scott is the
Nomura professor and director of the
program on international financial
systems at the Harvard Law School where
he's taught since 1975 he's also
director of the Committee on capital
markets regulation an independent
director of Lazard limited a member of
the Britain woods committee and the
market monitoring group of the Institute
of International Finance and a past
president of the International Academy
of consumer and commercial law his books
include international finance
transactions policy and regulation which
has gone to 20 editions IC 21 and the
global financial crisis that means the
last crisis tonight in presenting
connectedness and contagion he will
address how to be better prepared for
the next crisis and welcome to the AEI
podium
[Applause]
thank you Alex for a clearer
presentation of my book then I was able
to make in many more pages and thank you
too
ATI for hosting this event so the thesis
of my book is that the heart of the 2008
crisis and most other financial crises
was systemic risk in the form of
contagion that that this crisis was
successfully stemmed with three weapons
lender of last resort liability
guarantees and capital injections post
crisis all of these weapons were limited
or a limited or eliminated by primarily
by dodd-frank as undesirable bailouts
dodd-frank purports to solve the
contagion problem without what I call
two wings and a prayer the wings are
heightened capital and new liquidity
requirements and the prayer is new
resolution procedures but you don't
allows the fire department even if you
believe you have more fire resistant
buildings that's basically what the
attitude has been post crisis thus we
need to restore and indeed strengthen
the three powers we weakened or took
away but bad news the likelihood of
doing so in the anti-bailout consensus
that exists today is very low so we are
dangerously exposed to future crisis
that's the thesis of the book so let me
talk about the elements of systemic risk
the main point of the financial system
of financial system regulation is to
prevent systemic risk of which there are
three varieties what I call the three
C's correlation connectedness and
contagion correlation refers to the
situation where the same external event
creates losses for a large number of
important financial institutions like a
housing price collapse that was part of
2008 that's not the focus in my book
connectedness comes in two flavors asset
connectedness were the losses of one
financial instance
ocean causes losses of other financial
institutions which sets off a chain
reaction of failure or liability
connectedness where the failure of one
financial institution in dangers the
funding of other financial institutions
largely the focus of network theory for
example of the settling of a bank
supplement tri-party repos were to fail
that would create a problem the third C
is contagion with the actual failure or
fear of failure of a financial
institution causes short-term creditor
investors to withdraw and withhold
funding for financial institutions
either out of the lack of information or
irrational panic or some combination of
the two so the first part of the book
looks at whether the problem in 2008 was
contagion or connectedness contagion in
my view was the primary driver of the
2008 financial crisis basically Asset
connectiveness Louis excuse me was not
the primary driver of the 2008 financial
crisis neither form of connectedness
leading up to Lehman's fall major banks
saw some deposit runs including National
City Wachovia IndyMac and Washington
Mutual but the Lehman Brothers
insolvency filing in 2008 put contagion
and overdrive a short-term creditors
headed for the exits fearful that the
institutions to which they extended
credit might meet the same fate as
Lehman Lehman's failure triggered a
major run on u.s. money market funds
starting with the reserve primary fund
which broke the dock on September 16
2008 owing mainly to massive investor
redemptions due to losses from the fun
significant direct exposure lehman an
example of connectedness the run spread
quickly across the money market fund
industry however including institutions
with no significant exposure to lehman
petition also spread to short term asset
back commercial commercial paper markets
as money market fund shifted their
holding to risk-free US government
securities in the interbank lending
market the London
offered rate LIBOR arose sharply and
many banks discontinued lending entirely
on the interbank market repower markets
also froze up that's what happened now
many people believe that asset
connectedness was the major problem
during the crisis the book examines has
claimed in detail while investors and
the reserve primary fund which had
overly invested and Lehman lost money
let's remember it was less than a penny
on the dollar and no financial
institution connected to Lehman failed
as a result of the failure of Lehman
moreover no financial institution
exposed to AIG would have failed if a AG
had failed
for example Goldman Sachs would have
experienced a maximum eighteen percent
loss of capital from its CD s
collateralized positions with Lehman
less than the conventional 25 percent
loan loss secured lending limits for
banks and this does not even take
account of the CDSs Goldman had on AIG
which further protected Goldman from
loss nonetheless the scenario coming out
of the crisis was there was
connectedness problem and dodd-frank
reforms largely focused on this city
designation by F sock is largely built
around connectedness look at the terms
of designation a lot of connectedness as
a central clearing for over-the-counter
derivatives the idea is we have to
utilize the losses we'll have a chain
reaction of failure and certainly
bilateral exposure limits these were all
parts of dodd-frank now well while one
can argue that these reforms are
desirable as preventive measures
generally apart from apart from the
experience in 2008 connectedness was not
the problem in 2010 so dodd-frank also
did something else which was to
legislate with respect to contagion as I
said at the outset three measures were
deployed during the crisis to stop the
contagious runs on banks and non-banks
lender of last resort liability
guarantees and capital injections in
lender of last resort the Fed was
created in 1913 to stop financial panics
the latest of which was a 1907
interestingly that panic 1907 started in
a non-bank sector at the Knickerbocker
Trust Company during the 2008 crisis the
Fed amply discharged slender of last
resort responsibility through a variety
of means lower penalty rate at the
discount window wider access for primary
dealers to the window and a term apps a
term option facility or major changes
and a number of new facilities were
created for non banks can't go into all
of them here but they included the
commercial paper funding facility to
purchase unsecured and a BCP paper from
corporate issuers and the money market
investor funding facility to purchase
assets for money market funds to provide
them with clinic with liquidity the
supply of this liquidity to the
financial sector doubled the Fed's
balance sheet to true two trillion
dollars by 2009 in 2007 before these
actions 91% of its balance sheet was
invested in US Treasuries by 2009 it was
only 25 percent due to this lending
expansion supplying liquidity to the
non-bank system was very important it
provided non banks with almost a
trillion dollars in loans and general
market liquidity more importantly the
very availability of these facilities
help stop the rough the Fed and in turn
the taxpayer actually benefited from
this new London
balance sheet expansion generates more
profits that that pays not much on the
liabilities bank reserves interest on
reserves which actually didn't exist
until the crisis and currency and makes
money on the ass the prospects are
remitted to the Treasury to sport
general revenue and 2008 these
remittances have risen to 40 billion
dollars as I said a key part of the Fed
lending was to non banks where the
contageous run
largely centered after the 2008 failure
of Lehman I estimate that today there
was about seven trillion dollars in
uninsured short term funding in the US
financial system was sixty percent of
this in non banks primarily money market
funds and broker dealers the ability to
lend to non banks and a crisis is
essential and I would expect this
percentage to increase as lending and
capital market activities are
increasingly driven out of the over
regulated banking system the legal
authority for this lending to non banks
was the then quite broad section 13 3 of
the Federal Reserve Act it provided that
quote in unusual and exigent
circumstances the board could authorize
a reserve bank to make loans to quote
any individual partnership or
corporation end of quote
where such loans were quote secured to
the satisfaction of the Federal Reserve
Bank unquote this authority to loan to
non banks by the way is quite separate
from the discount window authority under
sections 10 B and 13 two of the Federal
Reserve Act to lend to depository
institutions like banks now while use of
this broad authority to lend to non
banks was crucial in stopping the
contagious run after the fact it was and
continues to be widely attacked as
bailing out Wall Street this is despite
the fact taxpayers benefited from this
London now legitimate moral hazard
concerns have been raised about this
London but the beneficiaries of lending
were largely victims of that panic
without panic withdrawals from these
institutions Alex kind of alluded to
this they would have been solvent a
notable exception was AIG but in general
totally solvent institutions were beset
by these runs making them and so would
have made them in solve a puff of the
London now this anti-bailout concern
triggered radical calls for changes in
13-3 lending authority for non banks and
oddly such concerns did not
translate over to the feds use of the
discount window kind of focused on the
non-tax result was that the dodd-frank
act plays significant constraints on the
feds 13-3 lending authority what are
they
first the Fed can only now lend to non
banks with the approval of the Secretary
of Treasury under procedures adopted in
consultation with the Treasury
interesting Lee this requirement for
approval was first put forward by the
Treasury itself then headed by secretary
Geithner perhaps this was just another
chapter in the Fed Treasury turf war or
maybe guiding her thought this was a way
to protect the Fed from even greater
restrictions which indeed were then
actively being considered in the
Congress now one can argue with the
importance of this restriction though it
is clearly taking independent authority
away from the Fed some point collect
correctly to the fact that Paulson was
Bernanke's cheerleader during the crisis
but we'll all secretaries at Treasury in
the new anti-bailout environment be such
willing cheerleaders Treasury approval
would now carry a significant political
risk and the markets will know fed
support may not be assured which itself
could accelerate a road if we think it
is important for the Hep Fed to have
independence to lend to banks
why not to Nam banks and over ever
increasing important factor in our
financial system second the amendments
to 13-3 provide that the Fed can no
longer make one-off loans to single
beneficiaries such as it did in 2008 to
Arg it must it must come okay it must
now do so according to dodd-frank under
a broad program a Fed regulation
implementing this provision provides at
least five institutions must be eligible
for any FEHB program now if this means
eligible at the time the Fed provides
the first loan it may make it harder to
nipa contagious running the bug you got
to wait until five institutions have a
problem if it means on the other hand
ever eligible for a loan then it is not
much of a restriction but under that
interpretation the first loan could
trigger cries of inappropriate behavior
or even illegality third dodd-frank
required that all loans must be
collateralized before it was just the
satisfaction of the Fed and a lendable
value was signed to all collateral this
reigned in the feds authority among
other things to buy unsecured commercial
paper which it did for major
non-financial issuers of the crisis and
more generally deprives the Fed of
discretion on setting collateral
requirements forth the Fed can only loan
to solvent institutions again a
requirement not applied to banks just
non bets
now while ik solving SI requirement is a
cardinal principle in Bao Joe's 19th
century formulation of the appropriate
role of the lender of last resort many
have pointed out Charles Goodhart for
one that this is often been honoured
only in the breach okay here and abroad
now one reason for not requiring that
the central bank determined that its
borrower is solvent is the judging
solvency is extremely difficult should
assets be valued at mark-to-market a
price which might also already reflect
fire sale prices or should they be
valued at what they would be if the Fed
lent an underlying argument for a
solvency requirement is that lending to
an and solve an institution should be a
fiscal issue in which the Congress would
play a major role through appropriations
as it did indeed and tarp and I sort of
agree with this point of view but if
you're going to have that point of view
then lender of last resort needs to be
coupled with what I would call standing
tarp authority so that there is the
possibility that the Treasury can act
when the Fed can't
a fifth provision of dodd-frank provides
for disclosure all loans to non banks
must be reported within seven days to
the to chairman of the House and Senate
financial institution committees and
must then be disclosed to the public
within a year on the banking side one
change on the window all discount window
loans must now be publicly reported
within two years now the concern with
such disclosure requirements much more
stringent by the way than those facing
any other major central bank is that the
prospect of disclosure certainly within
seven days and even within two years may
discourage Bauer's concern with stigma
from seeking needed support
thus worsening the problem you want them
to get the support indeed in the crisis
banks in need of funding avoided the
discount window out of fear that their
borrowing might be leaked or uncovered
by analysts thus leading the Fed to
create the term option facility or all
bags whether in trouble or not could
attain cheap funding sixth dodd-frank
provides that banks can no longer pass
on discount window loans to their
non-bank affiliates such as broker
dealers without being subject to the
normal section 23 a limits on
inter-affiliate lending which would be
precluding a full path this means the
substantial borrowing by bank affiliated
broker dealers would have to occur under
the new restrictions 13-3 couldn't be by
the window and then passed up indeed the
multiplicity of restraints that are now
imposed under Section 13 3 but do not
apply to discount window borrowing which
is reserved to depository institutions
prompted New York Fed president Dudley
to suggest last May the Congress amend
its discount window authority to permit
loans to non banks however this is dead
on arrival because it would an effect
represent a repeal the dodd-frank 13-3
restrictions some of the Fed including
governor Powell and external Bernanke
have said that they can live with these
dodd-frank restrictions
but they have taken this position in my
view to stave off further restrictions a
number on November 15th of last year the
House passed the so-called form act
largely along party lines 241 to 185 of
Republicans for Democrats against the
bill has not been enacted into law but
it's passed the house under the form Act
the Federal Reserve could only loan to
non banks if at least nine of the twelve
Federal Reserve Bank presidents voted in
the affirmative
further all federal regulators of the
potential borrower which would often
include the SEC or even the CFPB would
have to certify that the borrower was
not insolvent
chair Yellen said at the time that these
provisions was essentially an Federal
Reserve lending to non banks this form
act has now been incorporated into the
house financial reform pepper now these
attacks on the feds role of lender of
last resort are not recent my book
recounts how opposition to any role for
a quote federal bank whether lending to
commercial or bank borrowers goes back
to the early controversies in our
history over the first and second
national banks Andrew Jackson veto the
renewal the charter of the second
National Bank in 1832 it's this debate
over federal bank institution that took
us so long to create the Fed in 1913 of
this debate still goes on all right so
the second part of the fight against
contagion were guarantees in October of
2008 the FDIC used its authority to
remove any limits on deposit insurance
for transaction accounts it's our key to
the payment system and increased
insurance limits on other accounts from
a hundred thousand to two hundred and
fifty thousand while dodd-frank
permanently increased deposit insurance
limits to two hundred and fifty thousand
it removed the authority of the FDIC to
raise any limits in the future without
resolution from Congress in addition the
FDIC established the so called temporary
liquidity guarantee program in October
2008 which gave depository institutions
and their holding companies authority to
issue new senior unsecured debt
guaranteed by the FTC this power was
also taken away by dodd-frank and by the
way the FDIC made money on these
programs there were no taxpayer losses
in addition in 2008 following the break
out of the run on the money market funds
the Treasury used this authority under
the exchange Stabilization Fund to
guarantee the money market funds this
had a major impact and stopping the run
on the funds this power was also taken
away by dodd-frank absolutely and not by
dodd-frank absolutely by the earlier
tarp legislation and by the way Treasury
made 1.2 billion of fees on this program
and never paid out asset now runs on
money market funds remain a problem in
my view which has not been cured by the
SEC is required floating net asset value
on prime institutional funds even a
funds post their true values investors
will still redeem they expect values to
go lower and SEC rules giving funds the
authority to limit or charge for
redemptions in adverse conditions may
just have celery bronzes Commissioner
Stein observed than heard assent to
their before the final tool used to
combat contagion was terrible as of June
2016
there had been two two hundred and four
point eight nine billion of capital
injections into banks and on this
injection Treasury made not lost sixteen
point two eight billion so Treasury had
money on this program the taxpayer did
not pay for this tarp expires by its own
terms
thus unlike the EU or Japan which have
standing Authority for capital
injections if the US needs such
injections in the future Authority would
would have to be obtained in the might
have to be obtained in the midst of the
crisis itself as it was in 2005
now while contagion fighting powers have
been curtailed defenders of dodd-frank
point to what I call two wings and a
prayer the wings being capital liquidity
prayer being new resolution procedures
the premises since contagion is much
less likely we need not worry much about
it anymore capital requirements are wing
one we have greatly increased capital
requirements no doubt about it now I put
aside the difficult issues about
methodology and capital requirements
leverage versus risk grade static Basel
versus stress tests etc but let's not
fool ourselves there are major
methodological problems and setting
capital requirements when they're not
done by the market now capital
requirements can reduce systemic risk by
decreasing the probability of bank
failure from any form and they generally
reduce moral hazard but no realistic
level of capital can prevent a run on
banks due to fire sales capital is
quickly eroded even higher capital
proposals like admati and malware
suggestion of the twenty to thirty
percent leverage ratio would not prevent
that failure in the face of contagion
and underlying this capital requirements
only apply to banks not to the ever
increasingly important non banks the
second wing was liquidity okay after the
2008 crisis we adopted again through
Basel certain liquidity requirements
most notably the liquidity coverage
ratio which has a 30-day horizon and
requires banks to hold high quality
liquid assets to cover expected funding
runoffs these requirements in effect
discourage short-term lending again they
do not apply to non tax as with capital
requirements there are significant
methodological issues largely around
runoff assumptions and what cons as high
quality liquid
in my view the new the new adoption of
private liquidity requirements
represents a retreat by the Fed from
providing public alkalinity as lender of
last resort the Fed can now say it will
only be a backup source of liquidity the
front line is the bank's liquidity
itself but ironically the private
liquidity requirements may actually
reduce collective private liquidity
because it requires each bank to hold
their own liquidity rather than making
it available to others in a crisis so
whether it really comes you know to
prevent Fed lending is open to question
said that two minutes I think I'll make
it so the prayer is resolution
procedures dodd-frank orderly
liquidation Authority gives the FDIC new
powers to resolve non-bank financial
firms including bank holding companies
whose failure upon a two-thirds vote of
the Fed governors and FDIC directors and
the Treasury are determined to pose
serious adverse effects to the financial
stability of the United States
if such a determination has not made the
non-bank financial institutions
including bank holding companies will
continue to be resolved in bankruptcy
such procedures in my view are not are
unlikely to deter contagion at the
outset without the requisite approvals
this new procedure may never be used if
it is used the FDIC has designed a
single point of entry procedure
requiring structuring at the holding
company level a major consequence of
which is that short term funding at the
operating subsidiary level were almost
all sorts of funding exists mainly
through banks and their broker-dealer
subsidiaries will be unaffected thus
some hope this will stop contention
since the FDIC resolution will not
endanger existing short-term funding but
whether such we whether such
restructuring will actually work
particularly for a major multinational
Bank is problematic highly problematic
and the procedure has never been tested
thus this is a prayer the reality is the
creditors of financial institutions will
run if a large financial institution is
put into any kind of resolution better
safe than sorry and we need to be
prepared for that
so resolution procedures are good but
don't think you've got rid of contagion
fighting just because you have it
actually works the other way easier to
resolve an institution if you know you
can prevent the contagion that might
follow from its resolution I won't
comment because Alex will be jerking me
off of this platform on kind of other
solutions to the problem like limiting
short-term funding but if we have time
to discuss it in the rep party in the
Q&A I'll talk about that so what are the
conclusions contagion in the non-bank as
well as the bank sector now
connectedness is the major systemic
research concern but dodd-frank was
focused on connectedness we know how to
stop contagion through the use of lender
of last resort guarantees and capital
injections but these powers have been
greatly weakened by legislation and due
to the failure to the fear of bailouts
won't easily be restored
third capital liquidity a resolution
will not safe proof the system from
contagion
even if homes are fireproof you still
need a fire department proposals to
limit short-term funding which they
don't have time to go into also I do not
think the answer so let's just hope we
do not have another crisis before we can
move beyond the fears of bailing out
Wall Street and are able to rectify the
situation thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks hell we have coming up three
outstanding discussants who will each
speak for about eight minutes I'll
introduce them all in the order in which
they will speak after they do will give
hell a chance to respond to them and
then the panel to exchange ideas after
which we should have some time for your
questions but we are going to adjourn
promptly at 6:15 to our reception our
first discussion discussant will be l
Broadus who is president of the Federal
Reserve Bank of Richmond from 1993 to
2004 having joined the banks for search
staff as an economist in 1970 and become
director of research in 1985 as a
Federal Reserve president of course he
served as a member of the Open Market
Committee al is a member of the board of
the Virginia Council on economic
education the Advisory Council of the
School of Business of the University of
Richmond the Executive Committee of
Richmond Renaissance and numerous other
boards annexed will repeat Kyle who is
the Charles E Smith professor of finance
at the University of Maryland's Smith
School of Business
Pete's research includes market
microstructure high-frequency trading
informed speculative trading and market
manipulation price volatility market
liquidity and contagion he's been a
staff member of the Presidential Task
Force on market mechanisms a consultant
to the Securities and Exchange
Commission the CFTC and the Department
of Justice and a member of the CFTC's
Technology Advisory Committee
our third discussion will be Paul Kupiec
who is a resident scholar at AEI and
focuses on the management and regulation
of financial institutions financial
markets systemic risk and the impact of
financial regulations on the economy
previously Paul was director of the
Center for Financial Research at the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
and chairman of the
search task force of the Basel Committee
on Banking Supervision and Hill
positions also at the IMF Freddie Mac
JPMorgan and the Board of Governors of
the Federal Reserve
Paul has also organized this event so
thank you Paul
for getting us all here all here and L
will start with you thank you very much
Alex I hope I didn't scare anybody
family want unlock my sign there I was
trying to I got punished now I was
trying to get to my ward I'm finally did
I couldn't open it I guess another sign
of age it took all the quiddity probably
there's only a couple of minutes from
now but it's very good to be here we
panelist as Alex's already mentioned
we're instructed pretty firmly in
advance to try to hold our remarks at 8
minutes which made me think reminded me
of Mark Twain's famous dictum that if he
had had more time he would have written
the shorter letter in any case I will
try to meet the requirement and I know
we're growing and maybe a little bit
late here
I believe the professor Scott's book
Hal's book is a very good book in a very
important book as you all know well a
lot of books have been a number of books
have been written from various
perspectives about the financial crisis
and several I would argue are really
essential to appreciating the scope
nature and significance of the event I
think of Ben Bernanke's recent memoir
Tim Geithner's stress test book
secretary Paulson Terry Paulson's book
they all I think help us understand what
it was like for policy makers who
actually confronted the crisis on the
front lines and I would answer that list
Alan blinders book which i think is in
the ditch the one that has
I think a phrase like musical chairs
somewhere in the title seems when I read
it it struck me as an especially lucid
review of the broader causes of the
crisis I had questions as to how
effectively it was dealt with as the
plate itself fell for me a house book is
a very valuable and highly useful
addition to this literature it provides
an intense and penetrating we've seen
this already in his remarks and intense
and penetrating analysis of the anatomy
of the crisis I almost want to say it
the section of the crisis which then
serves as a solid foundation for
evaluating the steps that have been
taken subsequently especially in the
dodd-frank law to prevent the more risk
more realistically mitigate any
recurrence but a slay anatomy of the
crisis I have in mind professor Scott's
clear delineation which he has already
reviewed and which is underlined by the
books title between Woodie charms as the
connectedness from what he terms
contagion as the systemic drivers of the
crisis and his conclusion as he noted
that contagion was the primary driver
and has the appropriate focus of efforts
to remediate the book argues
convincingly in my view that asset and
liability connectedness did not play
major roles in the core collapses of
Lehman Brothers in AIG rather contagion
which is simply today's augmented
version of an old fashioned wonderful
life bank run turn these events into a
broad and extremely dangerous crisis
given this Scott believes that the Fed
the FDA the FDIC and the Treasury
addressed the crisis appropriately if
not always smoothly and prevented a much
worse outcome with my background at the
Fed which has been reviewing and I not
was my bias but I happen to agree with
him from this premise
professor Scott proceeds to what I take
to be the book central point or
certainly one of the central points that
many of the sometimes politically
charged provisions of the dodd-frank law
are largely based on the mistaken belief
that connectedness was the prob
and that the provisions that restrict
the feds lender of last resort powers
and the feds complementary powers risk
severely weakening the government's
ability to successfully contain a future
crisis that want to rise us and I have
to say that this you know history
teaches us that that's a very likely
occurrence as we've already heard Scott
analyzes each of these limitations he
does this in Chapter nine which for me
is in many ways in the heart of the book
I can't review them all here actually
he'll it's done a pretty good job
already of doing that but let me just
give you an example of one that he's
already mentioned which I think really
gives you the flavor during the crisis
the Fed as you mentioned was able to
make section 13 3 launched independently
the non-bank financial institutions
dodd-frank as he's pointed out requires
such loans to be approved by the
Treasury secretary this may be
understandable and understandable
provision given the political climate in
which the dodd-frank law was written Ben
Bernanke himself seems to conclude in a
recent blog piece on emergency lending
that the requirement is the necessary
and workable compromise in a Democratic
Society and maybe that's right what if
the Treasury sector secretary who is
after all a political appointee at the
time of a future crisis is a highly
political figure not experienced in or
well informed about managing financial
crises I dare to suggest that it's not
difficult to imagine such a scenario in
today's world a strong perception indeed
absolute confidence among financial
market participants that the Fed and the
FDIC together can and will act
forcefully and immediately to stop Iran
would be essential to actually doing so
in more typical central banking language
the credibility in this regard would
need to be complete and robust if there
were doubts in mortgage that the
Treasury secretary would go along or
that he would delay andouille markets
would be at high risk of running if you
think there's going to be hit let
someone else
you think they're gonna be a hit let
someone else take that head I would say
the professor Scott's insistence on the
primacy of this reality with respect to
the Treasury secretary approval
provision and much else is for me really
the books principal contribution all of
us said that concerns about moral hazard
in regard and and reducing the risk of
taxpayer losses that helped drive the
dodd-frank restrictions are obviously
not frivolous
professor Scott I think does not deny
that it the enhanced capital standard
the quiddity requirements orderly
liquidation Authority and other actions
that have been taken to reduce the
likelihood of another crisis in the near
term and it's severe arts and its
severity if it occurs may prove
beneficial although I'm arguing I think
you already had argued with some of the
details but the book argues persuasively
and this is the key point you've already
made it that none of these reforms
individually in or all of them
collectively are sufficient to prevent a
run or to stop one once it starts there
is one other point I need to make you're
almost on a personal note for many years
led by my colleagues Marvin good friend
in jeff lacquer the Richmond Fed is
warned of the dangers of fit policies or
actions that involve it in credit
allocation as what Marvin my longtime
colleague and a good friend refers to
his credit policy as distinct from
monetary policy I share this concern and
I have to confess but I have to confess
that I've generally thought about it in
a mackerel monetary policy context
rather than in the context of the feds
lesser offense a lender of last resort
role Scott's book challenges me by
demonstrating convincingly that the
financial crisis was largely an
old-fashioned run in a new costume and
forcing me to ask myself whether it
would be feasible in dealing with the
similar future crisis to avoid some
credit policy risk I need to think about
this but you certainly have me thinking
and then asking the fundamental
questions here I feel compelled to offer
at least one nitpick if I may I guess
I really feel like I have to do that I
found the reasoning in a few sections a
little on the tenth side one section in
chapter 21 discusses the possibility
that the feds current reverse repo
program might meet might be used to or
result in in some way a crowding out of
a significant portion of the economy
short-term private and credit
liabilities and then it goes on to
consider this is where I got into
trouble hung has such a development
development might conflict with the fits
basic monetary policy objectives I got
really confused I will tell you that I
was on an Amtrak train south of
Washington behind a freak for anyone
read that section so maybe that adds
something to doesn't it but I do think
that's section and one or two others
could be simple but simplified a little
bit and clarified I probably said enough
by now the signal my high regard for
this book I can do it I can do it but in
closing let me salute an issue that the
very strength of the book for me
actually highlights if the Fed and the
FDIC needs strong and essentially
discretionary emergency powers to
prevent or confront runs how do we
reconcile such powers with legitimacy
requirements of a Democratic Society
this is obviously a critical question in
today's political environment with its
highly populist elements the dodd-frank
requirement of shredded Treasury
Secretary approval that we discussed
have launched not to non banks and
importantly the requirement the
accompanying requirement that the
secretary consult with the elected
president in making such decisions is
presumably a recognition of this issue
although we have seen with arguing a
problematic one resolving this
fundamental tension in our political
economy if that's possible at all is
beyond the scope of this particular book
although there's no question that that
hell is well aware of the issue I do
believe that some of the contributions
of Paul Tucker the former deputy
governor of the Bank of England
regarding the legitimacy of central bank
independence not only in the emergency
lending arena but
the monetary policy reader looking at
them as the sort of regime taking them
together some of his work I haven't
finished it all yet but from what I've
seen I think that's a good place to
start thinking more about these issues
thank you very much thank you this is a
really interesting book um he's got
three Capote house Scots got three C's
one of them is called connectedness
finance professors and macro economists
often use the term fragility to describe
what he's talking about with
connectedness or networks that have been
huge amount of research by young finance
professors on network theory and the
application and networks to finance and
how Scott comes along and tells us you
know a lot of this research is pretty
useless or is not really relevant to
explaining what happened during the
financial crisis for some good reasons
I'll talk about in a minute you've got
the second see that's that's not in the
title of the book the title of the book
is connectedness can in contagion the
second see is what how Scott calls
correlation I I like to think of
correlation as capital and its
associated with deleveraging so a big
shock in this case it was a decline in
real estate prices hits the economy and
it turns out that the real estate assets
that are affected a lot of them are in
the banking system their love their
mortgage loans of various types and it
turns out that loan-to-value ratios were
very high and it turns out that lending
standards had been relaxed so the result
was that when housing prices fell many
banks simultaneously or in a correlated
manner suffered hits to their capital
and there's a lot of macroeconomic and
finance research that says that when
that happens these financial
institutions are going to deal leverage
I mean that the reason they have to deal
leverage is that they were holding these
mortgages with leverage you know there
their capital is leveraged ten to one or
twenty to one or whatever the ratio is
that the regulator's allow them to hold
it and then there's the third C that's
in the title contagion and contagion is
what I call panic and I think what David
Ricardo calls panic and what a lot of
other people also would call panic now
health Scott's book gives us a different
view on the financial crisis and its
relationship to the dodd-frank act then
the the view that I've had before I read
the book so let me tell you the view I
had before I had to read the book and
then they were the way which it changed
my view the way I used to summarize the
dodd-frank act is is to think of there
had been a big capital hole in the
financial system as a result of
declining real estate prices and the
problem that needed to be fixed was that
banks needed more capital and the sooner
they got it and the more capital they
got the more the more rapidly the
financial system would recover and my
summary of the dodd-frank act was that
while the dodd-frank act did encourage
policies to make banks have more capital
mainly what it did is impose a lot of
regulations on the financial system so
that the authors of the dodd-frank act
had a face to trade off between simply
mandating more capital and mandating
more regulation and they chose to
mandate more regulation than to mandate
and more capital but health Scott's book
has changed my view on that and as he
points out on if you have a capital
problem or even if you don't have a
capital problem you can have a panic but
Charles Goodhart and David Ricardo and
other people are gonna are gonna tell
you that if you do have a capital
problem and it keeps getting worse
before the financial institutions
collapse or declare bankruptcy from lack
of capital people are going to try to
pull their money out and when that
happens you're going to have a panic and
the panic is not only going to hit the
the bank that maybe it was truly
undercapitalized and on the verge of
insolvency but that panic is going to
hit all the other banks in the system
regardless of whether they're well
capitalized or not it's going to be
indiscriminate and it's going to create
a crisis
and the crisis requires immediate
response and the immediate response
that's necessary to fight this contagion
or this panic is lender of last resort
facility or other credit support
facilities and they pretty much have to
be provided by the Fed and so Hal
Scott's book comes comes in and and says
if you look at the dodd-frank act what
you're going to find it's not just
imposing regulations on regulations for
regulations sake but there's a misguided
theory behind it and the misguided
theory behind it is that the feds lender
of last resort facility needs to be
curtailed and it needs to be harder for
for the Fed to provide liquidity support
to financial institutions though that
way may well need to be recapitalized
but in the meantime you've got a panic
going on and you need to address that
panic with some very strong immediate
action so he spells out this scenario in
great in great detail and it's changed
the way I think about the financial
crisis and it does make me worry whether
our Fed has the tools that it will need
to fight the next financial crisis
especially if might will happen the next
financial crisis originates outside of
the banking system that the Fed is
itself is most capable of making lender
of last resort loans to so that that's
the big picture there's some there's
some very interesting chapters in the
book that just describe the the more
details about what I just said so let me
mention a few of them first of all in
talking about connectedness he paints a
beautiful picture of Lehman Brothers and
Lehman Brothers itself is an incredibly
fragile institution they're huge
important connections between the
holding company and the subsidiaries and
Kross guarantees and so forth and the
result of that is that if problems start
within Lehman Brothers there is a
connectedness problem these problems are
going to spread throughout Lehman
Brothers and so Lehman Brothers
self as he paints in a very detailed
picture Lehman Brothers itself collapsed
in a very connected way but the sense in
which he's saying that connectedness was
not so important for the financial
crisis is that when you look to see how
the financial crisis spread from Lehman
Brothers to the rest of the economy it
didn't spread through connections it
didn't spread the Lehman Lehman was
defaulting to another two goldman sachs
and the goldman sachs defaulted to the
next one the next one defaulted to the
next one the economy blew up that way
instead lehman brothers just kind of
collapsed rather neatly through its own
internal fragility but it didn't spread
to the rest of the system through these
connections it spread to the rest of the
system through panic so the reserve fund
held some Lehman assets those Lehman
assets declined in value the investors
in that particular money market fund
lost some money so what happened the
investors who invested in the other
money market funds panic pull their
money out of those funds even though
those funds maybe didn't invest in
Lehman assets at all so he paints a very
interesting picture of how fragile
Lehman was within itself and also how
that that fragility was not what what
made things spread to the rest of the
financial system indeed if you look at
the collapse of Bear Stearns which had
happened months before Bear Stearns
collapsed in a way that was kind of
similar to Lehman and you didn't have
you didn't have the panic at that time
the panic waited until it could occur
later so interesting thoughts about
connectedness let me let me also talk
about correlation or what I like to call
capital I think that the financial
crisis of 2008 was largely a problem
with capital and the book has some
interesting chapters on contingent
capital as a way or Cocos as they're
called as a way to deal with this it
also has chapters on orderly resolution
Capital has one minute one minute left
and orderly resolution and other ways of
kind of bailouts and tarpon and how that
happened but I'll end my comments with
just one note about contingent capital
it's the one area where I slightly
disagree with the book contingent
capital doesn't need to be a long term
as a long term liability of the bank it
can be short term the key feature of
contingent capital is that it has to be
replaced that if the bank banks got
let's say one year maturity contingent
capital and it matures but the bank
can't replace it with new contingent
capital then right then and there that
that contingent capital is not being
replaced is going to get converted into
equity I'm so it doesn't have to be a
long term and the second thing about it
that that I slightly disagree with was
he says that the one one trigger
mechanism for contingent capital which
is securities that will convert into
equity when the bank gets into trouble
is that some one conversion proposal is
to look at an index of bank stocks and
the whole index of bank stocks declines
then contingent capital gets converted
how scott's book says that if that
happens that could kind of amplify panic
and and I think that's not quite right
because one interesting thing about
contingent capital if panic makes the
contingent capital investors not roll
over the capital so that it converts all
of a sudden there's this massive inflow
of new equity that the banking system
has just gotten from the conversion of
the contingent capital and I think
that's going to stop panics not not make
them worse so various mechanisms
recapitalizing or something we should
think about and we should certainly
think about worried about the ability of
the Fed to exercise the powers that it
needs to act as a lender of last resort
next time a financial crisis occurs
thank you people
[Applause]
in his new book connectedness and
contagion al Scott reminds us that
historically the first and most
important function of a central bank is
the provision of lender of last resort
liquidity to stem financial crisis
lender of last resort or LLR for short
was the reason that most central banks
were originally created and yet
dodd-frank comes along and it sort of
cuts off the Federal Reserve's ability
to effectively do lender of last resort
lending for much of the economy I'm
going to focus my remarks on lender of
last resort in his book how does a
superb job of distinguishing between
connectedness and contagion all large
financial institutions are connected
there's really no surprise there but
contagion is a property whereby the
well-being of one firm can impact the
well-being of many separate firms that
are not necessarily connected to the
firm in question for example the reserve
primary fund breaks the buck and soon
other institution only money funds
without exposure to either the reserve
primary fund or Lehman Brothers need
liquidity assistance from their parents
to meet redemptions the classic example
of contagion a run on one bank creates a
general panic and depositors run healthy
unconnected banks the Federal Reserve's
wide-ranging use of LLR powers in a
recent financial crisis has been
unfavorably portrayed as a taxpayer
bailout of the financial sector as a
consequence the dodd-frank act placed
new limits on these federal reserve
powers the lor is a complex issue the
emergency provision of liquidity
probably will always have the appearance
of a special privilege for a few select
firms and in a real sense it is lalr
protects financial firms from from
suffering fire sale losses and in some
instances from outright default the
justification of course for LLR is that
the run forces financial firms to
undertake fire sales which affect other
firms and while the runs may be rational
for short-term creditors they are not
always justified by economic
fundamentals LLR is based on the idea
that everybody can be made better off if
the government can prevent panic
redemptions but the feds LLR policies
were discretionary so it could be used
to save firms with unsound fundamentals
that should be allowed to fail the rub
of course is in the midst of a run you
can't tell the difference between a firm
that deserves liquidity support and one
that isn't and the judgment call can
always be open to criticism why say Bear
Stearns and let Lehman fail and then
save AIG the next week so this
discretionary policy created a lot of
problems and if you think about it the
need for LLR is somewhat ironic given
regulatory rhetoric financial regulators
are quick to highlight the disciplining
effects of market forces while almost
never described as such a bank run is
perhaps the most fundamental of all
market discipline forces many scholarly
papers are written to explain how banks
fragile business model borrowing short
and and investing long-term and opaque
loans is a market innovation not a
mistake it's before government safety
nets invest in investors required banks
to fund themselves using short term
liabilities and demand able deposits
precisely because this fragility imposed
discipline on the banks investment
decisions a banker with inadequate
liquidity was unlikely to be a
successful banker at least not for very
long
and so while regulators espouse the
enthusiasm for market discipline they
simultaneously argue that they need lots
of tools and discretions to prevent bank
runs and fire sales how Scott rightly
suggests that post-crisis politics are
stacked against new discretionary fed
lender of last resort powers however I
think the political sticking point maybe
not lender of last resort so much as
free the free and discretionary nature
of the prior Fed LLR arrangements the
Congress in the Federal Reserve in my
opinion should work together to develop
a new approach for lender of last resort
that relies on a market where
institutions pay the taxpayers to
purchase liquidity insurance coverage
before it's needed indeed how discusses
such a proposal in his book but I want
to go a little bit farther in the next
few minutes I have
the Federal Reserve should be required
to sell liquidity options now liquidity
options are options that affirm once a
firm owns can be presented to the
Federal Reserve and exercised as long as
they have appropriate collateral and
they would receive a loan from the Fed I
believe the Fed should tell two kinds of
liquidity options one that allows for
the term exchange of collateral ie I
bring bank loans to the Fed and I get
Treasury bills in return and one that
allows acceptable specified collateral
to be exchanged for reserve or balances
for a fixed term so there's a securities
lending liquidity option and enter and a
repo kind of blending option the
instrument I believe should be sold at
regular Fed auctions and they should be
traded in secondary market thereafter
the option should have specified
exchange terms haircuts and implicit
rates that are less generous than those
prevailing in the private security and
lending mark and repo markets the price
of these liquidity options would reflect
the shadow price of emergency liquidity
if bank liquidity coverage ratios and
net stable funding ratios these new
rules we put on systemically important
financial institutions if they were
amended to allow liquidity options to
satisfy this requirement we could create
a natural market for these options banks
would buy them this arrangement would
drastically improve the risk sharing in
the economy over the current self
insurance approach for liquidity
insurance which which I'll mention a
major if we did something like this with
a market market terms emergency
liquidity ask is access with no longer
be a special privilege but merely the
exercise of liquidity insurance on
previously agreed-upon terms and terms
that firms paid for the right to
exercise liquidity option the purchase
of these liquidity options and they're
used should be open to all financial
institutions not just depositories so
non banks as well she should have access
if a liquidity crisis were subsequently
to develop the terms of the liquidity
insurance contracts could be adjusted
and to allow the Fed to provide all the
emergency liquidity the economy needed
so they could lower the lower the rate
over the market rate change the
collateral terms they could adapt the
options and
still seldom and meet the liquidity
demands of the economy this approach
would remove the need for the Federal
Reserve to determine whether or not an
institution is solvent to secret
liquidity support if they have the
option and they have the collateral the
Fed would would honor the contract and
they taxpayer losses could be prevented
by setting appropriate haircuts and
grading the Fed reserve a priority on
any borrowing institutions that
subsequently entered bankruptcy impose
losses on the Fed I think a market-based
solution to some of these problems would
stem a lot of the issues are issues and
how brings up this and talks about it a
proposal and is in his book and I would
like to see I would like to see folks
take that up in a little more detail
because I think I think it solves many
of the problems that we discussed in the
book I think the book discusses a very
very important issue and it gives you
gives us a lot of a lot of food for
thought about the right the right way
forward LLR in particular I find to be
the most distressing problems created by
dodd-frank and thank you very much thank
you Paul and thank you to all the
commenters oh hell we have held some
time to respond in any way he likes to
those comments always thinking I'll
mention musical chairs and when
challenged after the crisis to come up
with a metaphor for a panic musical
chairs is a natural one and I ended at
this one imagine a game of musical
chairs that has 500 for a financial
system you got have a lot of one of the
problems is there a lot of actors they
had 500 people playing musical chairs
and but there's 700 chairs and the music
that's playing is a charming Mozart's
serenade and what it stops everybody
easily finds a chair we call that high
liquidity suddenly the music shifts to
raucous obnoxious popular music and 400
chairs are removed leaving 500 players
and 300 chairs and I think that's a
great picture of what happens in the
like hell comments on the comments yes
so now you end up with the reference to
Paul Tucker and the legitimacy of
central bank independence which I think
underlies a lot of this discussion to me
remember I rode on a TI person Peter
Wallison and I discussed co-authoring a
piece on contagion along the lines I
developed and Peter said to me well I
don't have any problem with that but
it's all the rest of the powers the feds
exercising over supervision and
regulation so if you're critical of that
I'll join you on the contagion but what
what I guess I would say is that I think
the Fed central bank independence of the
Fed is being more undermined in my view
by all these other powers that they're
exercising to regulation and supervision
maybe them being lender of last resort
it's it's a bigger picture contingent
capital you know we're willing to think
more I guess my central point is that I
wouldn't think that having a good system
of contingent capital says to abolish
the fire department I don't think you
would say that
so my central point our resolution is
you know even if it works we still need
to worry about contagion no imagine
Jamie Dimon calling of secretary Lew and
saying Oh heads up well we're going to
bankruptcy tomorrow is the response of
the secretaries oh no problem we've got
resolution procedures I don't think so
the first thing he's gonna think about
is the proverbial ass hitting the fan in
total panic okay in the world's
financial system you need to be prepared
for that and in terms of Paul you know I
as Paul pointed out I did actually hold
out this idea of going back to y2k was
actually Peter Fisher who when he was
undersecretary created this kind
of procedure in advance of y2k so we'll
be very clear to the market okay that
people have liquidity and you know it's
it's interesting because that idea runs
in the face of you know 25 years ago
when the Fed would talk about systemic
risk ambiguity now we needed ambiguity
about whether the Fed was going to
London Gerry quarter it's really big on
that in chips in the you know payment
system which was the earlier
manifestation of system like this and I
think your point fundamentally says no
just the opposite okay we need to know
in advance you know the beauty of lender
of last resort if it's strong all over
its engineered by options or otherwise
if you know it exists you like I've had
the problem oh that's why I'm Draghi
says I do what it takes and nobody uses
his facility okay
because as long as the power is there
people aren't going to run it's one
where you have ambiguity and people are
uncertain as to what's going to happen
is that they're going to do it I guess
the other thing I would say about and I
haven't thought through this about
proposal which I think a story worth
exploring is if you don't require people
to have these options then what happens
you go into a situation Weiman doesn't
have the option so Lehman fails now what
you can say is that everybody else has
got that option if they're run on they
had a way to protect themselves I think
you have to have a critical mass of
acceptance of the options and the and
the obtaining of these options in order
to solve the problem so you know yes so
they the idea that you changed the
liquidity coverage ratio and the net
stable funding ratio rules to allow the
use of options in replacing actual
instruments the banks will have some and
you have a secondary market so if Lehman
didn't buy any they could buy them from
the banks that don't need them and when
you observe the secondary market price
the liquidity option going up the Fed
has that right to step in and open up
the auction sell more you have a
monitoring vise in the secondary market
so you
you would expect dealer banks to
purchase or dealer financial
institutions to purchase and stockpile
these liquidity options and sell them to
people when they needed them and they
charge for I'm sure and you'd know the
price and you'd see the demand for
liquidity I think I think you would have
the the Fed wouldn't be caught
flat-footed like it was in the summer
when the commercial paper market blew up
and they were wondering what was going
on they would you would see it on
Bloomberg the market price of liquidity
skyrocket and they couldn't deny there's
a liquidity problem and they did some
more options and and make adjustments so
I think with that I think with that
provocative thought and we could have a
lot of fun talking to each other I do
want to fit in one or two questions Paul
I would just say of course the Fed could
when Lehman money so it could buy
options from Morgan getting we have time
for one or two questions we have one in
the back here I'm sorry will you wait
for the microphone to come to you please
thank you Andrew quali and a lawyer in
New York hi Scott
I hate to say this about a Harvard Law
School professor but I think this is
terrific and this is I went to Harvard
Law School so it's it's excellent I've
had the same issues and same concerns
during this whole dodd-frank development
part of dodd-frank is is fine capital
enhancement trying to eliminate
incentives bad incentives moral hazard
not very successful there but the key
thing I think that you you've focused on
is tying the hands of the Fed and the
Treasury I think they really are very
wrapped up and this is made worse by the
AIG case where the Fed has said that
they didn't have 13-3 authority in the
case of lending to AIG and taking back
stock that was considered not to be a
security interest their collateralized
by the judge judge is totally wrong but
if you are
an executive man I'm sorry you'll have
to come to a question if you have here's
my question why does the Fed my friends
at the Fed also think that section 13
three as amended does not tie their
hands very much
I think it's wishful thinking I don't
understand this and I think also the
resolution authority is is totally
useless when City goes down they don't
have time to resolve it so I'd also do
with you have I think that's a question
deal why would the Fed think that it
well I don't think they do secretary if
I were I had the Fed I would be saying
what the Fed is saying we don't have a
problem yeah well we do we want to
undermine confidence in our own
institution no I can tell you from my
private conversations okay I think the
Fed is extremely concerned about this
but and the first Fed official who
raises his hand publicly and says we
need to do something about professor
Scott's look oh you want to bail out
Wall Street again this is toxic it's
gonna take time they're gonna take a lot
of time okay I think we have come to our
our adjournment time however I want to
give any member of the panel one more
minute if you ever
I guess they were just I'm very
intrigued by Paul's my proposal I think
it's worthy of some additional thought
and investigation one thing you know in
the in dealing with the crisis an issue
that was that Bernanke thinks it's one
most difficult to deal with with stigma
getting banks to borrow well this is
safe is based on crouches it's good that
would be one benefit of it you know you
get around that problem
it's then that's why they had to start
the auction and the procedure to begin
with that way it would be built in right
up right up front I don't know just one
thing about Paul's that I think if the
Fed proposed that oh you want to give
them a dance protection you want to give
them a promise to bail them out
up and up a Fed for 12 years no I mean
within the political system today I
think that I think would be a problem
testify I think you sell people out the
fact that they're paying for the right
to have protection there but they're
paying tax payers for this and it's not
free any longer okay I think we got the
sense of the panel hell that you have
raised serious and deep problems in the
book which need addressing and we thank
you very much for coming to present it
thank you very much to the members of
the panel if you have more questions
we'll all be at the reception and just
ask us in the informal setting and with
that thanks to the panel
[Music]